vom stadion bis zur party bis zum
familientreffen bis zum berufsalltag mit
viel sicherheit der sollte sich impfen
lassen und möglichst viele davon
überzeugen aber wir werden sicherlich
zumindest die basismaßnahmen die aha
regeln und dazu gehört auch die maske in
bestimmten bereichen noch eine ganze
zeit brauchen das gibt's doch nicht
julian bild chefredakteur julian
reichelt dass wir uns auch an diese
regeln halten müssen selbst wenn wir
mittlerweile zu großen teilen 34
millionen deutsche geimpft sind voll
durch geben die frage ist doch gar nicht
warum müssen wir uns daran halten
die frage ist warum darf der staat und
das eigentlich vorschreiben ich nehme
mich als beispiel
ich bin doppel kämpft seit relativ
langer zeit das risiko dass ich mich
anstecken oder dass ich jemanden
gefährdet ist de facto nicht existent
zumindest nicht in einem ausmaß dass der
staat irgendein recht hätte mein
verhalten zu regulieren
es ist auch besteht auch durchaus die
möglichkeit dass ich jemanden angreifer
auf der straße die theoretische
möglichkeit besteht ja ist sie so groß
dass der staat mich deswegen ein sperren
darf nein ist sie natürlich nicht und
ich habe eine ganz einfache frage wenn
ich ein spannender höhere der inzwischen
in einer und ich mag ihn ans sparen aber
er spricht inzwischen in einer
selbstverständlichkeit darüber dass er
mir vorschreiben kann was ich mir ins
gesicht zu kleben habe oder wo ich lang
zu gehen habe oder wie fand ich mich von
anderen menschen teilen habe dass man
merkt dieses menschenbild wir können den
leuten einfach ohne jegliche grundlage
sagen wie sie sich zu verhalten haben
hat sich eingeprägt und ich habe das
gefühl die politik hat sich auch an
diese art und weise mit uns umzugehen
gewinn und hat freude daran gefunden
karl lauterbach wenn irgendjemand
zurücktreten müsste der belehrt er jetzt
boris johnson wenn das schiefgeht müsste
er zurücktreten wenn irgendjemand
zumindest von der bezeichnung des
experten zurückgetreten müsste dann ist
das natürlich karl lauterbach
niemand ist so berühmt geworden niemand
ist so prominent geworden niemand hat
sich so profiliert wie karotte was
niemand hat so oft mit fundamentalen
aussage falsch gelegen
niemand hat es so oft eingestanden
niemand hat sich so viele fans auf allen
dreien gestanden niemand hat sich so
viele teilen einfach ausgedacht für
seine schreckens propaganda um einfach
menschen angst zu machen
und wenn ich mir anschaue dorothea das
muss man einfach europäer die letzten
vier jahre hat man das gefühl einfach
nicht
gearbeitet sie war zuständig für die
digitalisierung wir wachsen immer noch
gerade in der pandemie sind wir die
absoluten fax weltmeister mich wundert
dass wir um den digitalen empfang aufs
handy zu bekommen nicht unser handy als
gesundheitsministerium faxen müssen
niemand hat in den letzten vier jahren
so wenig getan um diese pandemie zu
bewältigen wie doro wir und was sagt sie
uns jetzt wenn ich fit bin dann sollen
wir uns weiter testen testen testen
das heißt auch in der übersetzung die
politik möchte gar kein ausweg aus
dieser pandemie aufzeigen sie möchte
diesen zustand erhalten in dem die
bundeskanzlerin in der übersetzung die
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel oder der
gesundheitsministerien schwant mir als
kerngesunden doppelt geimpfte
verantwortungsbewussten risikobewussten
menschen sagen möchte was ich mir ins
gesicht zu kleben habe und ich finde
dafür gibt es keinerlei grundlage mehr
und wir müssen weg von diesem weltbild
und von diesem menschenbild dass wir
eine regierung haben die uns einfach
nach gutdünken unsinniges zeug vorteil
vorschreiben darf letztes beispiel wenn
es mir heute nicht gut geht und ich mich
seelisch belastet fühlen
von all dem was den letzten anderthalb
jahren passiert ist und ich habe ein
paar freunde und ich sage dir gehen in
die kirche und beten und singen uns das
von der seele
dann verbietet der staat das immer noch
ich kann nicht mit meinen freunden in
die kirche gehen und singen ich kann
auch nicht 20 geimpfte mitnehmen in die
kirche und anfangen zu singen das ist
ein grundrecht was ohne jegliche
grundlage eingeschränkt wird einfach
weil es der politik gefällt und aus
dieser gefallsucht des starken auto
autoritären inzwischen staates müssen
wir dringend wieder raus und es liegt an
uns bürgern diesem punkt immer wieder zu
machen und gleichzeitig singen gestern
abend das ist ja das gegenbeispiel
daneben zehntausende im wembley stadion
gekommen
ok wenn zehntausende gesunde menschen
singen der staat hat sich bei gesunden
menschen erstmal gar nicht einzumischen
und der staat muss argumentieren wir
müssen nicht argumentieren warum wir
diesen regeln nicht folgen wollen der
staat muss erst mal erklären warum er
diese regel überhaupt erlassen darf und
natürlich darf er menschen die keinerlei
gefahr darstellen
zumindest nicht eine gefahr die
irgendwie über das allgemeine
lebensrisiko hinausgeht irgend etwas
vorschreiben das was wir
zu erleben ist der staat schreibt uns
vor du musst dich anschnallen auch wenn
du zu hause auf dem schreibtisch stuhl
sitzt du darfst nicht mehr über die
straße gehen weil du überfahren werden
könnte ist das ist genau der eingriff
den der den der staat da gerade vornimmt
wir haben im ganzen corona ja eigentlich
fast jeden tag das corona radar gehabt
die zahlen die immer höher gegangen sind
die maßnahmen immer wieder auch für
richtig erklären sollten wir wollen
jetzt einmal schauen wie denn momentan
in die karte aussieht denn mittlerweile
tatsächlich ein ganz anderes bild
deutschland ist eigentlich komplett grün
und das ist natürlich ein gutes zeichen
farbe der hoffnung unter 50 selbst dass
man könnte die zahl mittlerweile auf
unter 10 sätzen in ganz deutschland die
instanzen sind sehr sehr sehr niedrig
und das natürlich ein zeichen dafür dass
wir jetzt also endlich dann die
maßnahmen nicht nur lokal sondern zu
großteilen wenn nicht sogar ganz
abschaffen sollten also die instanzen
auf die man sich immer wieder bezogen
hat sehen jetzt auf einmal ganz anders
aus dann haben wir zum thema inzidenz
man etwas sagen die instanzen haben in
einer geimpften welt eine vollkommen
andere bedeutung als in einer nicht
geimpften welt wir haben kroner besiegt
es gibt großartige wissenschaftler und
großartige forscher die haben corona für
uns besiegt wir müssen weg aus diesem
incidents weltbild das wenn irgendwo
irgendwer eine krankheit bekommt die
geimpft gar keine relevanz mehr hat auch
nicht mit der data variante wenn wir uns
großbritannien und die horrorszenarien
von karl lauterbach angucken wenn du
jetzt großbritannien gucken was karl
lauterbach man kann den menschen nicht
oft genug sagen was er behauptet stimmt
nicht ich kann krank werden ja genau wie
ich stopfen oder grippe bekommen kann es
macht aber nichts wenn ich gebe deswegen
müssen wir unseren zuschauern auch immer
wieder sagen lassen sie sich impfen es
ist sinnvoll aber der staat hat aufgrund
der impfung keinerlei recht mehr in
unser leben in dieser weise sein zu
können lasst uns also auf die impfquote
gucken ich habe schon gesagt 34
millionen aktuell das hat der
gesundheitsminister vor ungefähr 30
minuten nochmal getwittert macht er
jeden morgen 34 millionen deutsche
aktuell voll durchgeimpft und welche
impfquote ist jetzt erforderlich für
normales leben was sagt die
bundesregierung interessant das
robert-koch-institut diese woche mit
diesem papier das ist noch mal
mitgebracht habe vom
robert-koch-institut wie gesagt welche
im quote ist notwendig um corona zu
kontrollieren dass kohl ich einmal
runter ganz ans ende ins fazit dieses
papiers
dann nämlich nach dem man verschiedene
kurven berechnet hat was würde das
möglicherweise sind zur modellierung für
tote für krankenhauspatienten intensiv
patienten bedeuten bei verschiedenen
impfquoten wieder aufzumachen und das
ergebnis des robert-koch-instituts ist
am ende
man brauche in deutschland eine ziel im
quote von 85 prozent
das ist das entscheidende 85 prozent
ziel quote für geimpfte damit normales
leben wieder zurückkehrten in genau und
darüber hat natürlich auch karl
lauterbach tweet und hat geschrieben
dass ärger ich schätze die lage richtig
ein bei der delta variante sind
mindestens 85 prozent geimpft nötig und
tatsächlich auch luise zahl auch diese
teil man kann da gar nicht scharf genug
widersprechen
diese zahl ist erst mal vollkommen aus
der luft gegriffen die hat einfach
jemand aufgrund von modellierung jetzt
anderthalb jahre nicht gestimmt haben
sich ausgedacht und natürlich das ist
das schlimme an dieser teil ist es eine
fantasie zahl die wir niemals erreichen
weil wir werden sie aus vielen gründen
nicht erreichen wir werden sie nicht
erreichen weil wir am anfang zu wenig
impfstoff hatten nicht schnell genug los
impfung konnten wir werden sie nicht
erreichen weil unsere region nicht mal
in der lage war eine anständige
werbekampagne fürs impfen auf die beine
zu stellen die haben mit jemandem
geworben fürs impfen günther jauch der
gar nicht geimpft ist das kurz angucken
wie wie zum beispiel die franzosen das
machen ja ja und wie wir das machen bei
der bei der plakatkampagne für das
impfen ja also so machen dass aktuell
die franzosen wie liebevoll sie werben
für liegt gerade nicht vor dann erzählt
ist ganz kurz das foto ist eine knutsch
szene ja eine ganz tolle romantische
knutschszene so kommt das leben zurück
also daher könnte tatsächlich zum impfen
animiert genau das ist auf jeden fall
besser als jemanden zu zeigen der sagt
ich bin geimpft obwohl er nicht
geimpftes und sich gar nicht impfen
lassen muss und ist auch jeder weiß wie
im fall günther jauch entscheidender
punkt bei den 85 prozent ist aber
folgender das ist ein ziel das wir nicht
erreichen werden und auf dass die
politik nur eine antwort hat die hat sie
ja eben genannt mit jens spahn weiter
und maßnahmenvorschläge das ist der weg
in den endlos lockdown du sagst hatte
die wenig erreichen werden also um die
34 millionen umgerechnet knapp 40
prozent durch gamestar die werte in
deutschland
haben wenn wir diese zeit aber haben die
regierung hält an 85 prozent fest und
wir erreichen sie niemals bedeutet dass
wir werden nie wieder in die normalität
kommen oder müssen sie irgendwann da ein
bisschen lotto spielen wie bei den
instanzen da hatten wir die top 35 die
100 die 207 sich das bisschen ausgesucht
es ist es ist gar kein lotto die aussage
war immer das leben ist wieder da wenn
jeder dieses impfangebot hatte
inzwischen wir alle kennen viele
menschen freunde bekannte verwandte ist
es kaum möglich in deutschland nicht
geimpft zu werden wenn man geimpft
werden will
ja und das ist der master wenn ich für
mich entscheide ich möchte nicht geimpft
sein ich möchte das risiko eingeht ist
es ja vollkommen okay wichtig ist dass
wir einander nicht mehr gefährden die
menschen die angst vor corona haben und
nicht corona bekommen wollen können sich
impfen und können inzwischen geimpft
sein und damit muss das leben zurück
kommen und ich hab mal etwas mitgebracht
heute ja weil es mir einfach wichtig ist
weil ich glaube das was wir da im moment
erleben ist für uns und für unsere
kinder der weg in ein katastrophales
menschenbild und in eine form von
unfreiheit und in eine form von
regierungsamt und umgang mit uns der
nicht unserem unserem wunderschönen
grundgesetz entspricht eines der
schönsten bücher die in deutschland wie
herausgegeben worden
dieses buch annalena baerbock hat gesagt
niemand schreibt ein buch allein dieses
buch tatsächlich nie von einer person
allein sondern von den müttern und
vätern ins grundgesetz geschrieben und
ich habe es mir einfach mal angeguckt
unsere grundrechte die sind ja
abwehrrechte gegen den staat das heißt
was können wir vom staat verlangen und
wogegen können wir uns wehren wenn das
trotzdem mit uns macht artikel 1 kennt
jeder menschenwürde die würde des
menschen ist unantastbar
schon da würde ich sagen wenn die
bundeskanzlerin sagt sie kann mir als
folge fünfte mensch vorschreiben dass
ich eine maske die mich in meiner atmung
einschränkt im gesicht tragen muss er
sehe ich das durchaus sehe ich das
durchaus kritisch
artikel 4 glaubens- gewissens- und
bekenntnis verhalten die freiheit des
glaubens des gewissens und die freiheit
der religiösen und weltanschaulichen
bekenntnisses unverletzlich die
ungestörte religionsausübung wird
gewährleistet wird sie nicht sie wird
gerade eingeschränkt und wenn nicht die
religionsausübung einschränke habe ich
dafür besser einen verdammt guten grund
schulwesen das gesamte schulwesen steht
unter aufsicht des staates
nein tut es nicht man hat das schulwesen
aufgegeben gerade hat
dritter gegner man hat unter das
schulwesen unter aufsicht der eltern
gestellt und sagt den jetzt wir können
den kindern noch ein fach mathe bio und
englisch der beiring der staat hat sich
in den letzten anderthalb jahren als
allerletztes um die kinder und die
kinder in der schule gekommen artikel 8
versammlungsfreiheit alle deutschen
haben das recht sich ohne anmeldung oder
erlaubnis friedlich und ohne waffen zu
versammeln massivst eingeschränkt im
moment ja und interessanterweise wird es
auch besonders strengen eingeschränkt
wenn ich irgendwie probleme mit dem habe
was die regierung da gerade an corona
maßnahmen veranstaltet und interessanter
letzter punkt berufsfreiheit und verbot
der zwangsarbeit berufsfreiheit alle
deutschen haben das recht beruf
arbeitsplatz und ausbildungsstätte frei
zu wählen wir haben in der korona
pandemie erlebt dass menschen die sich
genau gegen diese corona politik
gewendet haben jan josef liefers
versucht worden mit berufsverboten zu
belegen man hat gefordert wieder man
darf nicht mehr im tatort einen
kommissar spielen
wir haben uns so weit entfernt in den
letzten monaten von diesem wundervollen
buch und das ist das ist das was unser
maßstab und unser leitbild sein sollte
und das kann ich leider im moment nicht
beim gesundheitsminister nicht bei der
bundeskanzlei erkennen und bei karl
lauterbach schon gar nicht der
inzwischen sein eigenes gesetz
gleichzeitig passiert noch was um diese
impfquote über die wir gerade gesprochen
haben diese ideologische impfquote 85
prozent zu erreichen für druck gemacht
auf kinder und jugendliche sich impfen
lassen wir haben einen arzt gestern
begleitet michael achenbach und der hat
genau das bestätigt druck auf kinder und
jugendliche
es gibt jugendliche die fühlen sich auch
zur impfung getränkt und das finde ich
nicht in ordnung wenn wir jugendliche
impfen weil sie sich gezwungen fühlen
letztlich weil weil sich die erwachsenen
nicht ausreichend impfen lassen
dann ist es schon
dann ist die verantwortung nicht da wo
sie hingehört also der impf druck auf
kinder und jugendliche julian hier ist
die politik gewissermaßen ab so linder
kinder als wir hören in letzter zeit ja
immer wieder ganz viele kinder möchten
sich auch freiwillig impfen lassen
nachdem man den kindern anderthalb jahre
gesagt hat wenn ihr euch nicht an die
regeln halten dann stirbt oma kann man
doch da hier nicht mehr allen ernstes
von freiwilligkeit sprechen mich
erinnert das ein bisschen an die burka
debatte wo wir immer sagen aber viele
frauen tragen die bürger auch freiwillig
nein natürlich trägt keine frau die
burka freiwillig sie traut sich nun
nicht mehr zu sagen dass sie
unfreiwillig trägt und eine ähnliche
unfreiheit erleben wir im moment auch
bei kindern den wir sogar ihren wenn ihr
euch nicht impfen lassen gefährde die
andere menschen die übersetzung ist
lasst euch bitte etwas spritzen was ihr
nicht braucht weil erwachsene es sich
nicht spritzen lassen wollen das ist ein
komplett eine komplette umkehr unserer
unseres menschenbildes wir sind für die
kinder da und nicht die kinder zu
unserem schutz und ich sag euch auch
warum das im moment passiert wir werden
es erleben dass nach den sommerferien
die schulen nicht wieder so öffnen
werden wie wir schulen brauchen wie
schulen unser recht und vor allem das
recht unserer kinder sind die politik
wird auch das abendfüllend vergeigen und
ich sage euch warum weil zu viele lehrer
nicht zurückkommen werden zu viele
lehrer lassen sich gerade nicht impfen
deswegen machen wir gerade druck auf
unsere kinder und das ist natürlich das
größte risiko vor einer bundestagswahl
hier paaren sich gerade auf schreckliche
weise pandemie und wahlkampf die politik
hat angst davor dass ihr großer bluff
nach den sommerferien auf liegt dass die
schulen natürlich nicht so öffnet werden
dass millionen menschen erleben dass
ihre kinder nicht zurückgehen wird und
damit wir das bloß nicht unsere
bundesregierung übernimmt baut man jetzt
schon einmal vor und es ging nicht
anders wegen der delta variante wir
mussten ist so tun nein muss man
natürlich nicht es ist politik versagen
was dort gerade passiert und die
forderung muss seine kinder nach den
sommerferien wieder in die schulen und
bitte bitte schiebt die verantwortung
für ihr versagen nicht auf eltern und
gerade stattdessen ich weiß nicht wie es
bei dir ist wir sind schon mal
vorgewarnt worden in den ferien sind ja
dann auch hier in berlin nur noch 400
wochen bis es wieder losgeht das heißt
es wäre theoretisch auch möglich gewesen
jetzt schon mal eine lösung
haben für nach den sommerferien statt
dessen sind wir schon mal vorgewarnt des
regierungswechsel unterricht wieder
weitergehen könnte unsere regierung weiß
nicht wie viele lehrer überhaupt geimpft
sind unsere bundesregierung und die
landesregierung die kommunen haben keine
antwort darauf was passiert wenn lehrer
sagen wir kommen nicht mehr zurück und
wir kennen das alle wie viele
fehlstunden und kranke lehrer ist schon
eine pandemie gab
und da rechnen wir jetzt noch mal drauf
lehrer die sich nicht impfen lassen und
dann sagen solange die kleinen
rotzlöffel hier nicht geimpft sind
kommen wir nicht zurück weil wir sind ja
natürlich dann eine risikogruppe wegen
der lungenentzündung die wir vor acht
jahren mal hatten der schulunterricht in
deutschland wird nach den sommerferien
ich lege mich da fest wenn wir weiter so
machen und wenn es da keinen druck auf
die politik gibt und ich sehe nicht wer
dennoch aufbauen sollte so nicht
stattfinden und damit der politik dass
im wahlkampf der regierung nicht um die
ohren fliegt sagt man uns jetzt es ging
leider nichts anderes wegen welt